I am Nicholas B with recent TV and today
we're very happy to be talking with
Justin Amash he's a congressman from the
third District of Michigan and he's one
of the leading libertarian Republicans
in Congress representative Maj thanks
for talking with us thanks Nick go blue
we've got the sequester coming up in
just a few days should the sequester go
forward as planned well some sort of cut
should go forward and it's got to be at
least to the level of the sequester so
if they do anything to replace the
sequester then you got to see at least
the same level of cuts and we're looking
at 85 billion dollar roughly I've seen
different numbers I think they can
monkey around with the accounting a
little bit but you've got at least have
that like any of the alternatives that
are on the table the President Obama has
pushed forward a plan that would cut
more than that through some spending
cuts and some tax cuts John Boehner and
the Republican Congress passed to two
pieces of legislation that you voted
against simpson-bowles has come up with
a different thing or any of the
alternatives on the table worth voting
for well I don't think there's any
reason to raise taxes right now I mean
we're not looking at any sort of
substantial reform to entitlements or
any other major program so why would you
even put taxes on the table it's it's
ridiculous so you think the Republican
Party will be full square against all of
the cuts going forward even the ones
affecting defense spending well right
now it looks like Republicans are moving
forward to the sequester but you know
they've said they put two replacements
on the table I don't think the
replacements are adequate because what
they do is they eliminate the
discretionary cuts in this coming year
and they spread it out over multiple
years and they push it into some
mandatory spending programs but we can
only control what happens in the current
Congress I can't control what happens
down the road someone could undo out our
their talks active talks that you know
about going on to come up with some kind
of replacement for the sequester none
that I know of well with that we'll
leave it there thank you so much
representative Justin Amash of the third
District of Michigan thanks for talking
to reason TV thanks now
you